ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS FACTOR.
FORGES BRADFORD CABALLERO-
CHEVY DALLY DODD THE RAZA
EGGMAN GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG
HUESO HER TADO JONES LAYERED
LEYVA MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN
NEWMAN NIELSEN A SHOW OF BOTH.
PAN PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO
SKINNER STERN AMBERG WHITE
HOUSE SKI WIENER WILK. MEMBERS
OF A QUORUM IS PRESENT. WITH
THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE. WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR DODD AFTER WHICH WILL
BE LED BY THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR AND WILL
WATCH TO REMAIN STANDING FOR
THAT. CENTER DOT. FATHER MOTHER
GOD WE PRAY WITH MY ANGELO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENCE
DURING THE HARD AND MEAN DAYS.
FOR THAT WE HAVE YOU TO LEAN
UPON. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENCE DURING THE BRIGHT AND
SUNNY DAYS FOR THEM WE CAN
SHARE THAT WHICH WE HAVE WITH
THOSE WHO HAVE LESS. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENCE DURING
THE HOLY DAYS. FOR THEN WE ARE
ABLE TO CELEBRATE YOU AND OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR FRIENDS. FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE NO VOICE. WE ASK
YOU TO SPEAK. FOR THOSE WHO
FEEL UNWORTHY WE ASK YOU TO
POUR OUT YOUR LOVE AND
WATERFALLS OF TENDERNESS. FOR
THOSE WHO LIVE IN PAIN WE ASK
YOU TO PAY THEM IN A RIVER OF
YOUR HEALING. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
LONELY WE ASK YOU TO KEEP THEM
COMPANY. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
DEPRESSED WE ASK YOU TO SHOWER
UPON THEM. THE LIGHT OF HOPE.
YOUR CREATOR YOUR THE
BORDERLESS C. OF SUBSTANCE. WE
ASK YOU TO GIVE ALL THE WORLD
THAT WHICH WE NEED MOST PEACE
AMEN. AND SALUTING OUR NATION'S
FLAG I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. HE HAS A STRONG. MEMBERS
TODAY WE HAVE SENATORS BATES.
AGER AND LIMóN PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY GOOD MORNING SENATORS
CAN YOU HEAR US. ALL RIGHT.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ. REPORTS FROM COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THERE ARE NONE.
BUT RECOGNIZING ANYONE KNOW
THERE ARE NONE. PLEASE
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS BILLS WILL BE DEEMED
READ. CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE WE HAVE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS WE HAVE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH THREE CAN BE PRESENTED
THIS MORNING BY SENATOR WORKS
OR WHAT ARE YOU READY. YES MR
PRESIDENT I AM SO TO ALL FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF CYNTHIA FLORES
IN VICTORIA HAS CEDED TO THE
AGRICULTURE AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD. PRIOR TO THIS
APPOINTMENT MISS FLORES WAS AN
ATTORNEY FOR THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS IN LOS
ANGELES MISSISSIPPI PREVIOUSLY
SERVED IN A NUMBER OF POSITIONS
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS INCLUDING AS CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. BOTH
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED ON A
FIVE A VOTE IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON THE TWENTY SEVENTH
OF JANUARY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR. DEBATE ON THE
SUPPLY MET. EARNINGS SEEN NINE.
MA'AM SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA. ATKINS
I BAKER. I PORGES NO BRADFORD
HI CABALLERO. HI CORTESE I
DALLY. NO DODD. FIVE TORONTO HI
EGGMAN. I GONZALEZ. I GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. I HER
TADO HI JONES NO FLARED I LEYVA
I MCGUIRE BYE MELENDEZ NO MAN.
HI NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. A CHAU
ABODE. PAN FIVE PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN
I AMBERG ALL RIGHT I WHITE
HOUSE SKI FIVE WIENER AYE WILK.
I SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA.
NIELSEN I CHAU A VOTE. CALDERON
TELEVOTES AUGUST TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS FIVE THE I MADE IS
CONFIRMED IN. SIR WHAT. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO IS A CONFIRMATION OF
GETTING A CRACK OFF TO THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT BOARD
MISTER KRAKOFF PREVAILS IT
PREVIOUSLY SERVICE CHAIR THE
STATE MINING AND GEOLOGY BOARD
AND AS CHAIR OF THE INDEPENDENT
REVIEW PANEL AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL HE
WAS APPROVED ON A FIVE A VOTE
IN THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT.
UNSEEN NINE MINUTES SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF FILING
TO. ALLEN I ARCHULETA ATKINS I
BAKER. I FOR JUST. BRADFORD HI
I HAVE A ADAM. I CORTES HE I
VALLEY. DODD FIVE TORONTO FIVE
EGGMAN. I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO I HER TADO.
HI JONES. IT IS LAYERED HI I
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ NO
MAN I NEWMAN. I NIELSEN. A SHOW
OF BOTH. PAN FIVE PORTANTINO.
FIVE ROTH. FIVE RUBIO FIVE
SKINNER I STERN I AMBERG I
WHITE HOUSE SKI. I WIENER I
WILK I. I'M SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA BARGES. DALLY NO.
GROWTH NO JONES. NO NIELSEN. A
SHOW ABOUT. CLOSE TO CLOSE ROLE
TELEVOTES ALL RIGHTS TWENTY
EIGHT KNOWS FOR THE APPOINTMENT
IS CONFIRMED. SURE WHAT FILE
ITEM THREE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE IS A CONFIRMATION OF THE
FOLLOWING APPOINTEES DR YOUNG
KING CHEN TO THE AGRICULTURE
BORTON ACUPUNCTURE BOARD EXCUSE
ME THOMAS PIERCE THE BOATING
AND WATERWAYS COMMISSION- LILLY
AGAIN SALAS CHAVEZ AND
ALEXANDER ISRAEL TO THE ARTS
COUNCIL. DR SURAYA L. HANSEN TO
THE COMMISSION ON DISABILITY
ACCESS KENYA BRAZIL AND ROGER
CELLS ARE TO THE OFF HIGHWAY
MOTOR VEHICLE RECREATION
COMMISSION DR ALLEN JUNE AND
ROBERT SHIREMAN TO THE WESTERN
STATES COMMISSION FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION. THESE APPOINTEES
WERE APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON THE TWENTY SEVENTH
OF JANUARY SPECTRALLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SCENE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
APPOINTMENTS MA'AM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. ATKINS I BAKER. HI
PORGES AYE BRADFORD I CABALLERO
I CORTESE I DALLY I DODD. I
TORONTO I EGGMAN. I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH I HERTZBERG I HUESO.
FIVE HER TADO FIVE JONES FIVE
LAYERED I LEYVA I MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN
BYE NIELSEN. OCHO ALTHOUGH HI
PAM I PORTANTINO I ROTH. I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN HI I'M
BURKE FIVE WHAT COUNTY I WIENER
I WILK I. I'M SO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI. CLOSE ROAD
TELEVOTES FIVE THIRTY FIVE
KNOWS ZERO THE APPOINTMENTS ARE
CONFIRMED. MEMBERS WERE AT THE
POINT OF THE ARE. FILE ARE
THERE ANY COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. AT THIS TIME.
SIR PORTANTINO YEAH THE OF. THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
MADE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE IN
AT NINE THIRTY. BY GERMAN
ASCENDED RATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
MEET IN. TWENTY FORTY THREE OH
TWO. FORTY TWO OH THREE AT NINE
THIRTY CENTER DORADO. THE
SENATE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
FIVE OF WILL MEET. IN THIRTY
MINUTES OR UPON THE GERMAN OF
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS IN
ROOM THREE ONE NINE ONE. K.
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WILL MEET
UPON THE GERMAN OF
APPROPRIATIONS IN ROOM THREE
ONE NINE ONE. J. IF THERE'S NO
FURTHER BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS
THE JUSTICE COLOR THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY FEBRUARY EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AT TWO PM THANK YOU.
MEMBERS THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME ADJOURNMENT MOTION
WILL BE MADE. WILL RECONVENE
MONDAY AT TWO PM ENJOY THE REST
OF YOUR DAY THANK YOU